well in 25 years of doing radio I've
gotten to do some very very cool things
on the air including I have given away
$5,000 I've given away ten thousand
dollars I've given away twenty thousand
dollars i have given what we've given
away a lot of money over the years
different different promotions and
contests and things today we are hitting
a milestone we're giving away the most
money that we have ever given away in
one single award anyway here on the air
right now last month we held the 55
thousand dollar financial literacy
challenge for high school students in
honor of Financial Literacy Month
sponsored with our friends over at
Xander insurance the challenge was
simple high school seniors fill out a
brief money survey and a 15 question
personal finance quiz and that put them
in the entry in the drawing and all
kinds of different scholarships and
things were awarded and and if they were
underclassmen we give away some some
computers and things the grand prize a
40 thousand dollar college scholarship
for one high school senior and when our
winner found out that they were the
winner they made a trip to Nashville I
was not required but they did agree they
came to Nashville which is very cool so
in the lobby of Ramsey solutions right
now we have our forty thousand dollar
college scholarship winner her name is
Allan McGregor she's joined here by her
mom Lee on the mic and her dad Jeff is
in the audience hey folks how are ya
great welcome welcome congratulations
thank you so much I'm so excited to be
here you don't look like you're
particularly weighed down with this
forty thousand dollars doesn't it's not
it's not betting you at this point
definitely
I love it so I assume our team called
you guys or somehow and let you know so
tell me the story of what happened when
you found out you hit of that your name
was drawn and you're getting forty
thousand dollars what happened how did
that happen well I believe public
relations had kind of been in touch with
my mom about it before I found out and I
got home from dance really late one
night and my mom started asking me hey
do you remember upon for the Dave Ramsey
scholarship because you know do you
remember I've applied for so many but I
was like oh yeah I think I applied for
that one and when she told me I was very
excited but I still was not aware of the
amount yet and then she continued
talking and when she told me in the
amount my mouth just dropped and I was
speechless haha had to be a little party
going on at your house at that night
definitely guessing very cool very cool
so you're graduating obviously in just a
week or two a few weeks and where you
going to go to school in the fall I'm
going to the University of Georgia okay
now you're a senior in Tupelo
Mississippi yes right so sec fans
everywhere have to know why Georgia and
not Mississippi State or Mississippi
well I'm playing a major in fashion
merchandising next year and University
of Georgia has a very strong program in
fashion merchandising I feel like get
some good opportunities there there you
go very good decision ok that's how you
do it that's how you pick something out
you pick somebody that knows how to
teach it and that that's wonderful so
obviously that's what you're going to
study now what is it you want to do in
fashion merchandising them I think I
want to be an international buyer work
for a large scale fashion corporation
around the different markets you know
all over the world there's a lot of good
opportunities with that I can grow my
business as well sounds like a pretty
seriously fun career yeah little travel
yeah that's not to get to see the world
very cool that's a great great very good
so I'm Lee when the PR team I guess our
publicity team got in touch with your
our PR team and said hey we drew the
name and it it's Ellen's name what went
through your head well I told her the
next day when she called I said
no yesterday you may I thought I wasn't
excited I literally was stunned I mean I
didn't jump her scream or do anything
because that [ __ ] does not happen in
our house every day there's somebody
calls and tells you that so I think I
was just speechless I think I've ever
gotten that phone call it our yeah I'm
saying office and then my husband came
home I was by myself at house and he was
like are you sure i said well i think
i'm sure and then when i told ellen
tissues like are you sure i was like i
think i'm sure i'm today because i was
really glad when she called back the
next day okay and that it wasn't one of
your friends punkin yourself is
happening and we had told Ellen when she
started looking at Georgia and other
schools I mean we've had this
conversation for a year and a half we
put a lot of prayer behind this as well
and I said you know you're gonna have to
come up with some scholarship money yeah
connect up you go step across state
lines kiddo you're going to bring it and
she's worked hard and she's applied for
a lot of that's why when they called I
wasn't sure she's applied for so many
scholarships that's so time-consuming
but she's worked hard at filling all
these things out and answering questions
whatever she's needed to do so how many
others has she gotten well we know of
one that she's gotten besides this one
and then we just got an invitation
yesterday to the high school for
scholarship night so that means that she
should be receiving another one all
right good go excited so this filling
out thing for scholarships turns out it
works go figure exactly so Ellen how did
you know to do the Dave Ramsey
scholarship I'm in marketing right now
and actually brought my teacher with me
today she's been really helpful and she
required when they we got the class and
she required our whole class to sit down
and get out our laptops and apply for
the scholarship so I'm very thankful
that she did that oh that's cool and her
name was let's give her a shout out
since she's sitting here her name is
Miss Brooks Pratt ok miss Brooke Prince
okay very cool while miss Prince thank
you for teaching marketing I always
liked marketing in high school can you
imagine me like your marketing go bigger
but yeah very cool well that's the kind
of teacher that changes lives is
somebody that does something like that
so thank you thank you Miss Prince very
well done and you know it you know by
filling that out not only did you
obviously get 40,000 but it plants the
seed and everybody in the classes ed
that you could go get scholarships
instead of just getting neck-deep in
student loan debt and being part of the
problem and so that's a good teacher
right there that's a tea that's the kind
of teacher that changes a society so
very cool and as
part of this scholarship award of course
we are giving five thousand dollars
worth of dave ramsey foundations in
personal finance high school curriculum
and so hopefully you can teach it next
year because we're giving it to you for
free or at least to the school and
you'll have to help us arrange it so
that'll be great and get some of these
young people learning how to stay out of
data and how to be on a budget and use
common sense with their money and and
then when they sit down and you know
then they'll always be the legendary
moment that the Allan McGregor won the
scholarship I mean that'll be very part
of the history the part of the legend
now from now on it will be in our house
well it's part of our legend it's the
most money I've ever given away in one
fell swoop I'll tell ya it's a lot of
money that will go a long way towards
georgia and georgia is a good school I'm
a UT grad and rooty fans so we have a
lot of fun around the SEC poking at each
other but George is a great school and
you'll do good and I have heard of their
fashion merchandising so I actually did
have heard that a couple times about
them so you've done good research there
that's very very cool alright so Ellen
congratulations thank you brother yeah
go get them oh well go make us all proud
and I hey when you graduates in send us
a video or something so we've got it
Mike and thought about you getting ml
yeah getting through the whole four
years and making it I love it
congratulations y'all very cool I year
that's our financial literacy contest
winner a forty thousand dollar
scholarship baby who does that we do
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey you
guys Rachel crews here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I
I've my very own YouTube channel yes
that's right it's kind of better than
the dave ramsey channel don't tell them
I said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you